[Music]
jigsaw was directed by the spirit
brothers the guys behind predestination
and Daybreakers two films I really
enjoyed this is now the eighth film in
the Saw franchise after saw the
supposedly final chapter that came out
seven years ago and we are restarting
again with a bunch of people who are
trapped in a horrible deadly game
devised by the killer jigsaw but jigsaw
has been dead for many years so who is
orchestrating these events is it a
copycat is it the actual jigsaw killer
what's going on here if you guys saw my
review of saw I did with my friend Matt
Brando you know that I really enjoyed
that film and some of the sequels saw -
and saw six saw threes okay but four
five and seven I thought were really bad
and after a while the series forgot its
roots it forgot its psychological roots
and it became a Gore fest about traps
and really nothing else so I was excited
for the prospect of somebody who hadn't
really been involved with the previous
soph films coming in to direct a new one
all these years later because the
possibility of reinvention is very real
jigsaw however does follow for the most
part that tried-and-true formula of the
Saw films especially the sequels there's
a police procedural aspect where we have
detectives trying to figure out what's
going on there's of course the people
trapped in jigsaws game in an eventual
third act reveal that lets you know that
a whole bunch of crazy shit happened at
one point in time and you have to put
all those pieces together so I guess in
that way I was let down by jigsaw
because I was hoping that they would
have a film seven years later with more
of a reason to exist beyond let's make
another Saw movie because this really
does follow the specific formula that
the sequels have invented for the Saw
films it doesn't really go back to the
psychological roots of the first
although there are some traps that are
less gory than others and it's nowhere
near as over-the-top as the last few
soft films got it at least has some
restraint but it tries to please the
people who really enjoy the gory er
aspects of the sequels as well as the
psychological aspects of the first and
so in some ways this film can be
appreciated by both saw
fans the ones who just want the
psychological element and the ones who
just want the gory element but at the
same time there isn't really anything
new here I do think it's better than
soft for saw five and saw seven it's
well directed it looks good in regards
to things they have changed it's mostly
stylistic choices and aesthetic choices
this is the first saw film to be in the
2:35 aspect ratio so it feels more
cinematic than the others the last few
saw sequels began to feel sort of like
an elongated miniseries that just kept
going and going with this plot that kept
twisting and turning this one feels more
cinematic and more like a film the hyper
sped up quick cut editing that was
jarring in the other films with weird
sound effects and people screaming
that's gone this movie doesn't have any
of that jarring editing so really the
only major differences in this film to
the others are stylistic choices which
is a directorial thing from a story
standpoint it's pretty much like all the
other saw films so I was hoping for more
but at the same time this is a lot more
watchable than some of the other saw
sequels because honestly critics have
never really liked any saw film even the
first saw film does not have more
positive reviews than negative and that
was a very highly influential film that
a lot of people really liked so I don't
really listen to the critics too much
when it comes to the Saw movies and if
you are a fan of the Saw films you don't
even have to listen to me just go see it
you'll probably enjoy it it does have a
twist that kind of feels like a bait and
switch where you're like oh that's
interesting I wonder how they're gonna
oh okay well never mind this is not a
great film it's not even really that
good of a film I didn't care about any
of the characters really the traps were
semi scary but for the most part it was
just a lot of like wincing and then okay
it happened alright that happened and it
doesn't really feel as psychological as
I was hoping it would be I'm gonna give
jigsaw a C+ for a franchise to come back
seven years later without really doing
much of anything new beyond stylistic
choices that was disappointing but I
feel like if you are a hardcore softn
you'll probably enjoy it guys thank you
so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and gets
man eyes
[Music]